hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jessie and today we're gonna begin
some data from wordpress with a
wordpress installation that's set up
with the graph or uh what's it called WP
graph QL plugin and so that basically
allows us to get data from wordpress
with graph QL so we have a react site
with apollo and we're going to use that
to get the data and we're gonna bring it
in and display it and react so we've
been doing some of this in previous
streams and now we've got a little bit
more of the app build out so we're gonna
kind of dig a little deeper into that so
we've had a significant pool request
from yesterday from from Harshit and we
also just had a pull request today from
Sebastian so I haven't brought in
Sebastian's pool request yet so we'll
probably start with that and I'll pull
that in I have some changes that I was
making that I didn't commit yet so I'll
need to finish up with these quickly
commit that and then there'll be some
merge conflicts and this will be a good
opportunity to show what to do when
there emerge conflicts I don't know that
we've actually had any merge conflicts
on the stream so this may be a first
nice opportunity to see them and see how
we we deal with those then we'll get
into some of the the graph QL stuff so
we actually have the creator of WP graph
QL in the live chat right now which is
awesome so hey Jason thanks for joining
us and I'm really glad that you're here
cuz I'm sure we'll have some some
questions and let's see
let me I was doing some other stuff I
didn't have my normal setup okay so I
have my normal screens up now so let me
show you quickly what's changed since
yesterday if you want to check it out in
depth its pull request for so the the
link to the repo on github is in the
description of this video so you can
check out pull request for and see all
the files that change and everything
happens it's a lot so I'm just gonna try
to sum it up here so basically the
biggest change in structure is that we
used to have one component for layout
now and that encompassed the the app bar
at the top and then that that side
navigation drawer that we had now that's
split up so now we have a folder inside
components that's layout I know it's
really hard to see the folders over here
I can't I can't make this bigger easily
so I'll just describe is we have a
folder inside components that now has
several other components inside and
they're all separated out instead of
having one very large component and let
me think
oh also the the categories were brought
in let me show you this will be easier
for you to see let's see it looks like
you're hearing some mic pops let me
maybe move my phone my phone was was
kind of closer to the mic than it
normally is I'm gonna move it farther
away and let me know if you still hear
it now maybe it was just the phone okay
cool I think it might have just been the
phone so sorry about that I usually
remember to move it away but I didn't
didn't today
so let me show you they'll be easier to
just show some of the changes whoa
probably because I was changing things
and I didn't finish before I started
this dream this is from State alone side
component yeah I was was i working
inside component I think I was
see where I have it open let's go back
and see layout drawer okay in the drawer
yeah what's the one some things okay so
basically now in that side navigation
drawer we have all the categories listed
okay and then I went in after afterwards
and I set up the links so that when you
click on one of those categories it
pulls up just those posts from that
category so that was the change I had
hope to actually show you on the site
with the changes but evidently I messed
something up it's probably some passing
wood it's a line 50 for this loading so
it says the cannot read property edges
of undefined oh you know what I'm
messing with how we're pulling in these
categories so that's probably the issue
so I guess now's a good time to just
jump right in and show you what I've
been working on with with Apollo because
we need to get this working to even have
the app render so let me go ahead and
start my timer and we'll just jump right
into it and then I can go over after we
get this working then maybe we can pull
in Sebastian's pool requests so I'm
going to start this up if you haven't
watched before we do 25 minute sessions
of code during that time I don't really
look at the live chat that much so if
you ask a question during that period
I'm not ignoring you
well I guess I'm ignoring you a little
bit but not not for forever so once that
25 minute period is up then we'll do
five minutes of question and the answers
where I'll check out the live chat and
then it
and when I'm all done with the coding
I'll answer all the questions that are
left in the live chat so if you can
stick around for a little while your
question will get answered and if you
can't stick around you can always catch
the recording of this later on on the
free code camp Channel and hear my
response alright so let's get to work on
this so here's what I was doing I don't
need that up there I don't need this so
right now we're pulling in all the
categories and we're pulling in all the
posts from each category so if you check
this out here we're pulling sistas get
all categories and posts so when I word
click on one of the categories in that
side drawer we would pull in all this
data ok which works but I was thinking
do we really need all that data no we
don't actually we just need for each one
we just need the posts for that
particular category ok so the way we had
it set up before we didn't need all that
data because we were displaying all the
categories and the posts so this is what
I started to change this so that we
would just get the data for that
specific category so I pulled in below
here how we were getting a single post
by passing the ID and what I thought we
could do and what I hadn't done yet I
was I was looking through the
documentation for WP graph QL to make
sure it was possible was instead of
passing the ID I I thought we could just
pass the slug because I was already
using the slug in the in the URL so
basically with the link component we
have access to let me see if I can show
where it is ok here so we have access to
this props match params category and
that's the slug and we're passing that
with react routers through that link
component so I thought since we already
have this data why not try to pass that
data in and get our our post just for
that one category based on the slug and
a set of based on on the ID so I'm
assuming that that's possible it seems
like seems like that's possible so that
was what I was attempting to do was just
to kind of remake this after this
example so I figure there's not really
any need to take this out right now
because it's possible we might need it
and if we can't get this working I'd
like to just fall back on what it was
doing so for now thinking if we say
single category and
okay if we change this instead to slug
and this way I was confused I'm not
exactly sure what's going on here I it's
there probably is necessary to work but
I don't know if I can just do this and
have it work so I was going through the
documentation trying to find you know
some example but I couldn't really see
anything I saw things in the the sample
project that did the that worked with
the ID but I didn't see it with anything
other than an ID all right so we should
be able to get okay let's say category
and then I guess under category we would
then have category and edges node posts
I guess that would be but we how we need
to do it
okay so and feel if anybody has any
thoughts on on this process of how we're
doing it put it in the live chat I'm
going to try to keep glancing over since
you know I'm just kind of trying to
figure this out you know as we're going
so based on on how we're getting things
from the categories here I'm assuming
that we would have to have this
structure so let's go with that again
let me cuz let me look at what we have
for for posts forget all posts we post
and post data okay maybe we need
something more like this
yeah I'm gonna see if we can go with
this is if we have one category I'm
assuming that in that one category there
is something called posts that lists the
posts that are for that category so
let's just do this for now see what we
get from that category let's see and
okay there's a good discussion going on
the live chat about what looks like
spread operator so I'm gonna make sure I
read over that once we get to the
five-minute question-and-answer session
I want to see if this works first but if
you're wondering about this I'll will
get an explanation of it you know from
the live chat so if you can check the
live chat now you know you can check it
out now if you're watching later on and
can't see the live chat just hang in
there for a little bit and and I'll try
to get you an explanation okay so now we
have this data we want to pull this data
into our category J S component so
instead of get categories we're gonna
say get actually we gonna say single
category I don't want that to be I just
I want to say get single get single
category
cuz that matches what we're doing here
okay get single category and we'll have
to pull that in from up here so instead
of get categories it's single category
okay we're gonna have to change up how
we're doing things here as well but I'm
gonna save this and see if we can load
it enough and not get an error that I
can look at what data we're getting
we're still getting oh wait a second
just because I obviously that's not
going to work so I'm gonna take this out
briefly did I not change
did I not save that
Howry property as okay so we wouldn't
have the the edges now so we will have
to edit this a bit so let's go we won't
need this filter anymore because before
we are getting multiple categories and
we had to filter by the particular
category that we wanted for that page so
we can get rid of this filter just nice
it'll clean it up a little bit and also
we don't need categories edges instead
what we need actually the way this is
set up do we even need to map no we
don't because we're passing all of the
posts so we can come get rid of this map
completely we don't need this let me get
rid of some of the space okay so let's
get rid of that we'll still give it
we're gonna change these up so instead
of categories let's go with posts now
we'll go to a category and this props
data
like this will probably come in his
category right this prop stated category
all right so now now these will actually
work still in terms of just saying
category I don't think we'll need the
note anymore so we should be able to
just go we should be able to do this and
it should work at least I think we'll
see there's a lot of stuff going on here
it's hard to test it
okay this rough state of loading edges
okay I'm using edges elsewhere I need to
get rid of that then so where's my side
drawer pulling in
actually this doesn't this doesn't make
much sense because this is basically
unchanged we're still pulling and get
all categories unless I've done
something here let's mess this up I
don't it doesn't look like I've changed
anything there let's see I'm gonna check
the latch act quickly in case there's
something that you all are seeing that I
don't see
okay doesn't look like it right now so
I'm thinking just in case I did
something here that is is affecting this
down here let's for now comment all of
this out because we shouldn't need this
at all to render the homepage oh you
know what I don't know what I'm thinking
obviously it's gonna go through
everything USAir so instead what I'm
gonna do is just move this I'm gonna
move this down here I really don't think
this will do anything but you never know
still nothing this
hmm
maybe I'm not getting data let's let's
try to check out its inspectors go to
our Apollo dev tools let's see what
we're getting syntax error
let's check out our post see if we're
still getting pose syntax error it's in
this the same area we got last time when
we weren't actually getting any data
from WordPress this looks like the same
error so maybe there's something going
on within WordPress I mean I I didn't do
anything but we could check it out
that's I'm just gonna go through kind of
the last part of the installation
process again maybe it will reset
something so let's go to those
permalinks and change these up
and do that I'm gonna purge our cache
holy it always worth the shot to get rid
of the cache nothing and I'm gonna
refresh this just in case
whoa all right not sure what I did
something worked though okay now this is
the the big test here four categories
words no that is not working now we get
that same error again we briefly okay
alright so while we have this up here I
want to check out what data we're
getting so let's go it's going to react
for some reason the react dev tools
won't open from the drop-down at least
for me okay
is there some way that I can quickly get
down this this this tree here this tom
tree it's so annoying to open those up
okay so here's our data and we have
posts we should have our categories
hmmm alright let's check out or
a side component let's see what data we
have here
all right great we have the categories
there okay and it is in the form of
edges and then node and then name array
so this is how how we're getting this
double check so edges node that's that's
exactly what we're looking for let's go
back into categories here and see yeah
categories it should be categories edges
note yeah that's exactly what we want
hmm
okay so for some reason we're getting
the data some of the time and not all
the time it seems like if I do a hard
refresh then it works so I guess we'll
just go with that for now we do have
everything structured correctly so let's
go back here and we're gonna try at
least you can see the categories now so
before I this up again and we get an
error you can see on the side these are
the categories that we're pulling from
WordPress so these are all our
categories currently when you click a
category the URL changes to have the
name of that category there I'm gonna
try a hard refresh and see if we can get
something okay well this is better than
nothing we have an error message to go
by it's expecting a variable slug but
was not found in the props passed to
Apollo
okay so we're not passing a slug and we
should be passing it all right all right
let's see how we're formatting this
again category oh okay right right now
we're only asking for posts from
category but what we need is to get the
ID the name ID not idea name and slug
okay so this might have been my mistake
for just not not getting these let's see
if if this works now
and let's do a hard refresh hmm all
right what am i skin care you're
wrapping calories victim variable slug
but it was not fun okay so we're still
not getting not getting that let's see
if we have anything we should be able to
see the state all right so we got live
nothing in there which that's what I
thought normally we get an error you
can't see anything which that kind of
stinks but we can't see any of our
queries either okay I I'm pretty sure I
saved this I'm going to double check and
make sure I saved it and let me see you
know what I might not be formatting this
correctly let me go back to our
fragments okay maybe I'll need maybe
I'll need to do edges and then node
maybe I'm missing that
so edges node and then let's pull all of
this into here let's give this a shot
mm single category
oh you know what are we
maybe we're not now that I actually read
that error message I don't I don't think
our problem was even in here yet I think
the problem was it's expecting us to
pass something in and we're not actually
passing anything in so let's let's take
a look at how we were passing in the ID
for post and so that was probably in our
somewhere in our post preview or under
preview maybe not
let's see pseudo post detail let's see
there we go
okay so in our single post detail then
we're also pull doing this all right so
I'm guessing this is what we need to do
something more like this okay okay now
let's go back to our categories and
let's paste this in
I D so in this case we have slug match
params slug all right let's see lapis
unexpected token I ordered idea let's
see
I think I may have forgotten to copy
this this as well so let's grab that yes
we don't have any closing tag any
closing bracket for that one let's see
if that helps and whether or not this
works it'll be the last thing that we do
undefined
Oh actually this might work if we hard
refresh okay a different error which is
good that's progress
so my timer is up so I'm gonna do five
minutes of question-and-answer but we
are making progress I mean it may not
look like it but we're continually
getting different error message which is
which is progress if we were getting the
same error message over and over again
then that would be disappointing but
different error messages are hopeful
that means we're fixing the previous
problems and just working our way
through so I think we're close let's see
all right so I'm gonna do five minutes
and I'm gonna scroll way up to the top
of the live chat just work my way down
chronologically so if you just put a
question in there I may not get to it in
this session but I will get to it in the
next session let's see
hey everybody is here buddy saying hi
let's see
Sebastian's watching on his phone
how was that it must be hard to read oh
let me increase the font size a bit
that's that's got to be tough I'll do
that and then for now let's give some
more space
and I'll zoom in on this as well maybe
it'll be easier to see okay all right so
quanti sure says hello I'm new here nice
dream a welcome thanks for joining us
and joining in the live chat so you have
any questions or comments or any things
or anything
let let us know
okay so I mentioned I was going to talk
about this there's three dots that look
like the spread operator so in this case
in in graph QL they're actually
fragments so for those of you who have
been following along along with the live
chat you probably already have read
everything I'm about to say but if you
can't see the live chat this is
basically what's it is so we have
category data here so we're pulling in
categories fragment and then we're
bringing in category data so let's check
out fragments touch is so within the
categories fragment we have category
data's who are exporting this and that
simply is edges node and then we have ID
name and slug so what that means is
basically instead of writing edges node
ID named slug in here we just put three
dots and then category data and then it
saves a lot of space otherwise it would
we basically be repeating a lot of the
same stuff and it would make this look
huge so it's a lot more readable like
that and the same thing with post data
we could check out the fragments and see
instead of writing all of this we can
just write dot dot dot post data okay
and that's the I mean that's we're
putting in so it's basically like a
variable really I mean that's that I
guess it's what it is so it's like
saving this all to a variable but it's
it's a fragment right and then we just
pop it in here so cleans cleans things
up I'm not sure if there are other
benefits to it but definitely it cleans
things up okay
denaun jay says hey Jesse hey how's it
going
thanks for joining us
okay see
oops okay Blake just put in the live
chat well I just saw it maybe he put it
in there earlier reminding me about
starting the engross server so I'm
starting it now and I will paste in the
link for you all under the live chat so
the link I'm about to paste in if you
click on that you will see a live
version of what I have here running
locally on my computer you can inspect
it check it out with dev tools and it
kind of allows for a lot more real-time
interaction than just having to depend
on me being on this screen and showing
you things so all right yeah there's a
lot a lot of connections there so sorry
I forgot to do that I have remembered at
the beginning but we just had an error
message and I thought I'll wait till we
get it working and then I I forgot about
it okay
oh okay Jason I just saw the things
you're talking about there with the slug
so that's awesome that's perfect timing
that I saw that and that you put that in
because we're gonna start up our next
Pomodoro session so 25 more minutes of
coding and let's go back here and I'm
gonna try out so I didn't even look at
this error message but evidently we're
not getting what we need in here I just
saw Brookes comments I just saw the
bacon ipsum that's hilarious yeah I like
I like the bacon ipsum it's funny but it
makes me really hungry it's the only
downside and I don't have any bacon here
in my office unfortunately
okay all right so Jason has in the light
and remember Jason is the one who
created this word press graph QL plugin
so let's see your get single category
should look like categories like shrink
okay so let's go to our get single
category why do I have categories
I must have clicked on the error message
C get single category string okay missus
speak too slow straight babe okay so I
need to all right so I'm gonna attempt
to do follow Jason's advice here
so Jason let me know if I'm if I'm doing
this incorrectly but I think what I need
to do is say string and then category
slug okay
let's see what we have
okay I mustn't mess something up
I'll also I can check within my
component too just to make sure
category actually like if I go like this
then really I need edges node right if I
want to be able to do this yeah okay
all right evidently that didn't work so
I'm for this ere is further up the page
so that was not that's not coming in
okay Jason said actually I need the ID
of the category okay so so evidently I
can't do this with a slug I will need
the ID that's what it seems like from
from which ace insane in the live chat
okay I wondered about that make sure
like 31 string okay so jason says slug
support will come soon but it's not
available now okay cool that's not a
problem let's pass in the ID so let's
see I think it was supposed to be like
this but actually let's do this with an
ID so let's go back over to where we
have our posts and we'll just pull in
what we've done there in terms of the ID
oops
press the wrong thing there we go
swears our posts so let's pull in the ID
and I'd be here and then what we'll need
to do in our side drawer I have too many
things open I'm gonna close some of
these out because I can't see the names
of anything there we go
okay actually I just remembered in
Harsha's pull request he also did a lot
with linting so but I don't wanna I want
to make sure I give him credit so he did
a lot of stuff with linting so you can
check that out there's some extra NPM
packages in there for es lint
so that's in there as well so the
linting experience should be better now
than it was
all right so within our drawer we were
within our link
the slow okay let me check out I think
there is a way with react render or I'm
sorry react router to pass in more data
so let's bring up the documentation for
that and I still want to use the slug
here now actually how are we going to do
that you know what for now I don't think
we're going to be able to use the slug
as the URL because it would be fine if
users clicked on this link but if
they're just coming there from so just
coming there from a URL then it wouldn't
work would it I don't think it would
okay so here's what we're doing we're
gonna change this up a bit so instead of
our slug we're gonna go category and
category node ID and then we're gonna
need to change this up in our router as
well so let's go to our apt j/s file and
in our router we need to say category
and then we'll have this category ID
there okay
now what we should be able to do is pass
in in our category dodge ass down here
we're gonna use instead of slug we're
gonna use category ID or should we
probably could just use ID that'll work
I do want to double check where's our
post detail yeah we just use ID here so
since we're using the same code that we
are using to get the single post let's
just keep it the same
but what we do want to change is this so
instead of post ID we're gonna call this
category ID because that's how we are
bringing it in let me see I thought I
did that somewhere where did I do this
not Oh in our app dot J s we are calling
a category ID here okay so down here we
just changed this the category ID
let's save make sure I saved it here and
here and here and let's see hopefully
this will work
oh we're getting nothing at all that's
that's worse than we were at before okay
what did I do
you don't even need to use the ID for
the euro URL path or not oh okay
I changed the path so of course that's
not gonna work all right so here's our
categories now let's click it see what's
going on whoa
cannot read property edges of undefined
this profs data maybe what am I doing
wrong here
okay thanks Jason that was just what I
was wondering about so I shouldn't have
the edges and node here so I had added
that in before thinking that was the
problem but that really wasn't our
problem so let's take that out and see
what happens
oops I forgot to take take out the edges
note here I've been just says thank you
guys it's too late into the night here
and thanks for watching Abid sorry it's
too late I did do the stream a half hour
later than normal so hopefully on the
normal days you'll be able to watch more
so so goodnight thank you so much for
watching okay alright so now we're
farther down on the page and we're in a
different component let me do a hard
refresh though oh and we have a
different thing now okay so we're back
here two key categoryid cannot repro
pretty ID of undefined okay let's see
what's going on now this frosty
let's see
I'm gonna see if okay we're here I'll
shoot or night we can't get any queries
from that right now
actually I have two different names here
that all the other ones match up the
categories Oh actually they don't they
don't need to match up so yeah it wasn't
my problem
oh well we'll check it out anyway
yes still that's the same air this world
says do you ever get confused with so
many tabs open
occasionally it's hard to find things
but I have a place for everything that I
normally use so I have the general idea
of where everything is at so usually
doesn't take me that or that long to
find everything okay all right at this
point I need a way to figure out what
data I'm getting because that's really
the issue right now is I'm kind of I
can't I don't know what the data is so
I'm making these changes but I'm not
exactly sure what they're doing I'm just
going by the error messages so I need
some way to get whatever this is is
pulling in so maybe let's use that
tester okay Jason says we need to do the
need to do the loading check yeah yeah
yeah you're right okay
let's pull that from our post detail
page yeah
oh you know what maybe we are doing it
higher up now I shoot we are I didn't
even see that
food
let's make sure okay that's okay
all right let me grab this and we'll go
to hmm I thought I had the the page open
where we could test out there we go
I knew I had it someone I thought there
was a link here no there you go
oh okay I do have did I download that as
a plug-in now I can't remember
there we go I knew I had it up here okay
let's try well let's get our test one
let's get our URL the right one test one
slash demo graph QL all right and let's
test it with one that we know works okay
great so we know what works now let's go
with this one
oops we're not gonna alright you know it
for now let's take this out because we
obviously we don't have that fragment
available so we're gonna take that out
for now just to just to test this first
oops I don't have an ID okay let's see
let's get rid of this for now and let's
just put in manually we'll put in the ID
that we have here
let's see will that work no expected one
aid I probably need to put this in like
that
okay no category was found with the ID -
all right well this kind of works so if
you see it says no category was found
with the ID - I didn't mean to pass in
the ID - but at least we're on the right
track here in that it did look for a
category with a certain ID for whatever
reason I don't know what's up with this
with this thing yeah why is that the ID
okay
okay Jason says there's a variables pain
at the bottom okay she could do that I
guess
alright let's try to put in if we can
whoops
so he said so could I say ID like that
alright I'm not sure if that'll work
I've never tried to use the variables
before let's see alright still tell me
no categories found with the ID - hmm
uh-oh I okay I see now what you're
saying
so Jason says they're all base64-encoded
so the category would be category two
okay thanks
it occurred to me at some point that
like wait a second normal IDs in
WordPress don't look like this
okay no category was found with that ID
that's odd because I'm pretty sure that
there would be a category like that
let's go to those categories let's just
see what our category IDs are you two
let's check this one out it's not gonna
she's not gonna show us our category IDs
I guess not
let me see actually let's go back the
homepage was rendering before right we
should be able to grab see what the IDS
are from the homepage maybe
so now let's check out Cruz
whoa
we just got the data with the egg there
we go
all right
Oh actually I have an idea
I can get the IDS like this let's do the
what is it I can't remember the let's go
with WP JSON WP v - all right cool
alright so I just used the REST API to
be able to get the categories we do have
a category with ID - so category one has
the ID of - we have a category with an
ID of 6 that's category 2 we have an
idea of 9 and we have an idea of 1
okay Jason said I could also add
category ID to my query to get the
actual ID okay
so I'm I'm still not exactly sure why so
I do have something with a category with
akattak and ID of two so so that's not
the issue it's not that it doesn't exist
there must be something about the way
we're querying this that I don't know
that must be something wrong right it's
a category
I mean he's category the right path to
go with
I mean should we be using categories
instead that's not really outposts work
did it yeah
alright ok my timer is up so we're gonna
do another five minutes of
question-and-answer let me check my time
here might do another session
let me quickly make sure nothing I don't
need to respond to any emails or slack
messages ok nothing looks nothing looks
pressing ok so we should be good for
another Pomodoro session after this let
me check out where I left off I don't
think there's that much in the live chat
in terms of questions right now so I
should be able to get through whatever's
left
okay Abu now says just to let you
remember that I'm a keen follower and
that's surely not long from now I'll
meet up with you thanks for sharing with
us your skills shout hi to all others in
the coat house all right hey good to see
you in the live chat and let's see
quantity' says how long has it taken you
to build all this Blake said day 7 yeah
yeah so this is day 7
I haven't actually spent seven days on
this almost everything has been done
everything that I have done has been
done during the livestream so I mean on
an average live stream I get in like 50
minutes of coding and that's push it's
not exactly 50 minutes of coding because
even during this 50 minutes sometimes
I'll check back in the live chat so
somewhere around 50 minutes of coding so
I mean it's less than when we say
seven-day day 7 then it's less than
seven hours of has been put into this
project in terms of what I've done now
we do have pull requests that have done
a lot of stuff so it's kind of hard to
gauge exactly how long the project is
taking in - in terms of real like hours
worked because I don't know how many
hours you know everyone is put into this
who have been doing the pull requests
but I just like to count it by days just
so that you all can if you want to
watching them in order then it's easy to
tell near the sequence of the videos
actually I can so I have I do track my
hours let me see how many I have for
this projects bulletin reacts okay
actually so I have listed here 10 hours
total for this project so so I have done
some work outside of the livestream
because I've I've tracked 10 hours so
for me it's been 10 hours and now I lost
my live chat there it is
Blake says I like the latest post yeah
so on the I don't know where we put the
the page so we find it so Blake caught
that
okay so Jason says what I'm doing should
be working alright so we'll have to it's
probably some silly thing that I've
misspelled something or it's out of
place
oh okay awesome
so Jason just posted something I'm not
going to read it out because it'll be
weird I can copy and paste it
alright Marco just says hey Marco how's
it going thanks for thanks for joining
us here for the stream so let me copy
what with Jason just put in the live
chat so you all can see in case you
don't have access to the live chat right
now is I think this might help us out
this might be our answer so down oops I
can't put it down in the corner right
because my face is there and you can't
see it so let me put it up here okay so
so I got so basically this query that
he's giving me saying it you could do
it's a post query but it says where
category ID is in this case you know
we're using six but it could be any ID
then we're gonna get everything so I'm
gonna test that that out right now but
if that works then that is probably
going to be the answer to to what we
need to do here okay and he does say
that that that that particular query
uses the actual database ID not the
base64 encoded one so we will have to
change some things up to make sure we
get that ID but that shouldn't be an
issue that should be a pretty easy
change alright so let's go let's go here
and let's try this I don't remember if I
had a category that was six so let's see
whoops whoops I messed this up
that's weird that that character came in
all right let me clean this up a bit
let's see how we were doing this before
all right
so we need you like this
okay let's try a different ID so we knew
the two wasn't was one we had in there
hmm nothing those edges
yeah
need an opening bracket
jason says can you make sure you have
posts attached to these categories I do
that I have posted tattoo there I was
actually I was getting the posts earlier
before I made some changes so we can
double-check though in with the
WordPress API does it say here
I think if we look for our posts it'll
tell us what category they're attached
to categories okay so we have a post
attached to category one wow we did have
a category six okay category two okay
Marko yeah the data is fetched from
WordPress and that we in the past we've
used the WordPress REST API we're
actually using the graph QL API that
Jason here and the live chat has
actually built a plugin to give us a
graph QL API so that's what we're trying
to work on now are they published posts
I think that they are published they
should yep they're published okay what
is going on
now I lost where I had it here it is all
right let me
let me see if we get any posts like this
why are we getting two posts
okay Jason is asking what version of
graph QL Milan I'm on 0 dot 0 dot 17
should I upgrade would that help then
maybe that's the problem
I can't upgrade it shouldn't take too
long and I'm pretty sure I forgot to
restart my timer so let's do that okay
yeah let me let me upgrade then cool
okay this is actually awesome so
somebody had asked i've asked me on
twitter let me check and see
okay so brett had actually asked on
twitter if i could demonstrate how to
get the graph QL plug in and get it get
it working on wordpress so let me
demonstrate that now he actually asked
if i could post about it but i'll do
maybe i can do that one day but at least
for now I can demonstrate you know on
the video here how to how to do it so
let's go here let me refresh to get the
releases hold on
release
okay so let's download this source code
so you need to do the plug-in you need
to get the zip well yeah I'm gonna get I
said I think it could work either way
but I did it before with the zip and it
works so let's just stick with that
waiting okay
let's save this now we're gonna go into
WordPress to our plugins and we're going
to add a new plugin I'm going to click
upload plug-in at the top and then
choose file and now in our downloads we
can click on the zip file that we had
just downloaded we're going to open that
up and install that and I don't want to
activate it right now I want to
deactivate the other one first so I
don't cause any weird conflicts not sure
that it would cause conflicts but just
in case
let's see so this is our version 17 and
we're gonna deactivate that this says
version 19 but I mean obviously you saw
we just downloaded version 20 so it's
probably just in the documentation so
let's see I'm just gonna change it here
just so we know so 20 update so now it
should display properly yep so now it
says 20 let's activate that now you
Brett hit us about actually downgrading
so if you did want to downgrade you
could go in and just go back to a
previous release and you would just
download the zip for that release and
then upload that and use that as the
plugin so it's the same process you just
pick whatever release you want and make
sure you don't have both of them active
at the same time so right now this is
active I'm not sure if I have to do this
but I'm just going to go in and flush
out the permalinks I'm not sure if
there's an easier way to do this but it
seems to work by just clicking to a
different permalink setting saving it
and then going back to the original
probably don't even have to go back to
the original if you don't want to
alright so now let's try this out well
first we'll just see if it's working
great all right we're still getting data
now let's go back to to this see if we
get this to work no still no data okay
[Applause]
maybe
category in category name
all right so that's I mean it's there
it's available let's
[Music]
Carlos says this live coding is nice
it's like having Stack Overflow helping
you code yeah for sure I get a lot of
help from the live coding so I really
hope that I helped some of you or at
least the other people in the stream you
know help you with their expertise but I
definitely get a lot of help from this
so let's see that pose
you know I kind of want to check whoops
let's see where this is uh that's kind
of follow I really want to check this
out just in case it would take see if
it'll take that and I didn't all right
so so this isn't working for some reason
so we can get something else to work
to push based on the keyword search let
me try to zoom a neogeo can see got a
great array of category IDs used to
display objects from one category or
another
so you use category slug oh let's try
this and then we can this if this works
this would be ideal because then we
could use the category slug so we should
have a category slug of category one I
hope this works now I know still all
right what is going on
see if I can get anything to show up
like this oh that's okay to
automatically fill that out oh man
okay let's see alright so Jason has
checked this out
says the category name is also working
locally okay so it's working for Jason
so I must be doing something wrong on my
end here it's like I said usually when
stuff like this happens it's it's just
hmm
it's just something little all right so
all right so Jason's given me something
to paste in here let's try this out
let's get rid of that okay
Wow
that's interesting
why is the categoryid 43 where are we
getting let's see where we're getting
this for a categoryid
oh wait a second why is it still pooling
data
oh man I know what the problem is now I
apologize to everyone that had to sit
through this I never hit the button to
set the endpoint I'm almost positive
this is what the problem is all right if
you all want me to just quit
live-streaming forever after this I'll
entirely understand so let me know oh my
goodness that was the problem the whole
time everything that Jason was telling
me was correct and I just never reset
the endpoint so it was still pulling
data from Jessie while calm and of
course nothing we tried worked because I
had different categories and IDs oh man
yeah alright so if anything this is this
is a good example of not giving up and
realizing that it had to be I knew it I
kept saying it had to be some little
thing that I did wrong that had nothing
to do with the plugin that Jason had
made all right okay I'm gonna calm down
a second okay this is great news right
so it works and not only that but we
found out because it didn't work at
first we realized that we can use the
slug instead of the ID and so this is
actually gonna be better than it would
have been otherwise right so it's it's
not I wish it wouldn't have taken me
that long to figure out what I was doing
wrong but we're gonna have cleaner URLs
now
because we're gonna be able to use a
slug so let's double check you gotta
find the good and stuff like this or
else you just will want to quit right
okay so let me back up here a bit and
let's see categoryname yeah this is what
we want okay so let's see if we can get
it by category name great look at that
okay so we got our post by category name
so let's go back into our our app and
let's switch things around a bit so we
can get this this slug and search by
that and everything should work okay
yeah and thanks Jason for sticking
around and trying to help out for that
long that was awesome
thank you and it was my fault the whole
time okay all right where's our code at
let's do this okay so down here let's
switch it back up to say slug and
let me say slug there we need to change
it as well and our apt je s I think I
actually want to keep it as category
then category ID so for now let's let's
do that but I just want to change this
to slug okay let me save I don't think I
was saving it before okay so let's save
that here and this should what are you
getting the data back in chequered our
data format so he did have it's going to
be different it's gonna actually be
under posts and not category so let's
see
so we should probably move this out
entirely so we shouldn't even have this
in the categories anymore this should
really be in posts all right let's let's
do that let's move this to posts and
we'll call this and put it in here uncle
I will call this get post by category
this makes more sense I'm gonna breviary
so and we'll do this well this is called
a tag template right is that what it's
called when we do this with the template
literal right on the end I think so
I'm gonna do a query and it's we're
gonna go get by cats and now we're gonna
say posts oh but we need to put in we
need to do this as well so let's go with
slug oops
dollar sign slug and then what do we
want to put string was that it string
and was there supposed to be I don't
know if I'm supposed to be an
exclamation point at the end we'll find
out really quickly if it doesn't work
okay let's see now below that we want to
get our posts posts and yeah let me
double check post where category name
okay oops sorry I keep going back and
forth okay let me I ought to just copy
this
okay
okay we're category name and it's
instead of category one we're gonna say
it's going to equal slug we do that the
dollar signs slug okay slug and then
we're gonna have our post at which we
can double check the fragments and make
sure that that's what we really need
might as well do that post that a edges
node yep perfect that's what we need
okay let's go back to the post okay okay
that looks all right let's see all right
we need let's make sure I did this right
here now I need to change I knew there's
one more thing we had to change so get
posts and actually there's two things we
need to change because we got to import
that oh okay now we should be good oh
yeah okay
oops does not cane oops I messed up one
thing we switch this over to posts okay
oh hey what did I mess up here let's do
it still hardly that so I could see this
error again link now how did I mess that
up I didn't even touch that
hmm
all right we didn't even change anything
let's see this is we're not getting
category anymore on the category route
just posts of that category
okay all right did we change that then
get all categories
we should be right we can get rid of
this as well we don't need this anymore
right
is this the one we didn't need
okay Jason says I think you're trying to
pass that data down as if we had fetched
the category but we're not anymore I
said we should be right I mean we still
we're still doing get all categories
here right we're still calling get all
categories we didn't change that right
get all categories from categories on
the category slug route whatever view
that is whatever you are we in this is
the this should be the home view that's
what's confusing me is it nothing say
component side component render I mean
this one was working you know before
this was actually working don't a
category we take the slug and get the
post for the category or don't get the
category object itself we should yeah we
should be could it be so I was getting I
noticed in the and the slack chat for
for the plugin for WP graph QL someone
was having an issue with using Apollo
and it was sending it was saying that he
was sending like an options request
instead of a post
let's see
could that be the issue could in fact we
be getting back some things that we
shouldn't actually let's see what we
should do anyway to avoid this error and
actually display something to user in
case something goes wrong we should
check to see if these exist first anyway
so let's put that check in right now
okay Jason says the version zero point
zero point two point twenty fix the
options thing okay that's that's awesome
okay so let's let's go into our drawer
here that was side component drawer yeah
all right so let's go in here and we're
yeah down here
let's check first
all right let's try to do the check
let's see if this will be sufficient
good ok better so instead of an error
message now we'll get this loading logo
not working okay we'll get the loading
thing we are we're gonna switch back to
the newer logo as well at some point
okay
now the good thing about this is since
we don't have an error screen we can
actually look in our dev tools and see
what data we're getting and what
responses were getting so it looks like
I'm getting a 500 error okay so this
makes a lot of sense as to why we're not
getting the data so it's much much
easier to see what's going on when I
mean error messages are great but it's
it's much better
let's check the console fail to fetch
yes response for pre-flight has invalid
HTTP status of code 500 I said HTTP
really weird there y'all can laugh at me
a few hon okay Jason just said guren in
the live chat okay yep so it is still
doing the options thing for me
well it's sending the options right and
that's what's I guess causing a try
updating from the master branch instead
of that release okay alright we're going
to do another update to the graph QL
plug-in so everybody who's still hanging
in here and watching thanks for sticking
in there this has been kind of a
frustrating episode but I mean I'm I'm
still smiling I'm happy we're making
progress but I don't know what it's like
on your end watching if it's frustrating
or not but let's go where am I
I need to go over to to here and let's
grab the master branch right is that
what juice from the master branch okay
and we can see let ladies commit two
hours ago so this was very recently
updated and let's grab the zip so we're
going to download the zip and save that
great that was really fast
and now let's go into our plugins and to
add new plug-in and file we're gonna
install that just like we did last time
and we're not gonna activate it yet
because we want to disable the other one
first so let's do that so we're gonna
deactivate this one I wanna fact this
one did have the correct version number
already and we're gonna activate this
newer one all right
and now let's let's flush those
permalinks just to be sure
alright now let's give it a shot my
timer actually did go up for my session
but I want to see because if this works
we're so close to getting it to work I
think we can just be done and not do
another session so I'm gonna run over
just a little bit and see yes yes it
worked it worked
awesome ok cool so Jason had in fact
already fixed the issue it's just on the
master branch and it hadn't yet gotten
into the version of the plug-in that we
had installed so awesome awesome great
ok now here's the other big test if this
works then we're just going to take some
questions and we'll be done for today so
let's see No ok what's our problem oh we
didn't change here ok
my fault my fault we didn't I didn't
change these things right because we're
not getting category anymore
so instead of category let's just call
this post
pose right okay we're actually we need
to change up how we're doing this
should we map through this now
we should because this is giving us
multiple posts so we can't just say
posts idea won't work all right let's
check our render I'm gonna save this
it's not gonna work but I'm just gonna
say this and I'll forget let's go to our
render post component and see where we
add components where's render post set
where am I I'm missing this somewhere oh
where are we pulling that in from render
pose from render pose preview okay
those TV
what is going on here rendering render
those render for you okay we're just
bringing it in we're calling it
something different all right okay so we
have the mapping going on here but what
we could do is just skip this component
and go right to our post preview and do
the mapping in our category that's what
I think that's gonna be the best way to
do it so let's do that so we'll bring in
our post preview and our render post
preview will copy let's just copy this
we need to change a few things but this
will at least tell us what we need to
pass in save us some some time going
back and forth so here we're going to
replace this with this now we already
have our post here so we probably won't
need to change this post edges map we're
mapping over all those posts let's
double check our data here just to make
sure it's it is in fact what we want
post edges yep that's what we want okay
so post edges map our post preview post
node ID good this should work this
should work date and as your nice
I think this will work and this this
should work yeah let's save this see
what happens
those preview is not opes we didn't
bring in post preview so let's change
this to post preview those preview we
might be able to get rid of this render
post preview component I don't know that
we're using it anywhere else so that's
good we might be able to get rid of a
lot of code here Oh what did we do okay
pose edges map property edges can't read
property edges of undefined okay what
did I learn it a mess up here so we're
grabbing pose this props data posts
all right let me I want to see what data
we're getting so if pose let's see if
that okay let's see what with data we're
getting passed down here and our props
yeah we should be
okay we're not passing the slug what
happened here
I messed something up and we're not
we're not getting the right data okay
let's go back to our app let's see
category slug let's go to our drawer and
make sure we're passing in oops you know
what we didn't change this we need to
change this to slug that's our problem
okay
now let's let's see what's going on here
oops
alright let's give this a okay just do
still nothing but hopefully we get
something that can help us whoops here
we go okay so we have some data now do
we have we're still getting an error
still getting an error all right let's
see what we got oh it still gave us this
URL what happened there category knows
love
oh I know I know what I'm still I'm just
refreshing the same page let me see man
okay the euro is still using that d oj
Jason already caught that so sorry I
didn't see that looks like jason has to
leave thank you so much for all your
help I'm we're a few minutes away from
getting this so thanks for sticking
around I really really appreciate that
okay let's see all right so the problem
was I was trying to refresh the same
page obviously that's not gonna work
okay so let's see so did we get another
error let me do a hard refresh before I
start changing things okay now let's
check out what happened
we okay we did get an error unknown
fragments oh okay what did I do here
I suppose that's post that's yes
I wonder why that's saying it's post
data is an unknown fragment
hmm
all right well let's you know what let's
just grab this instead of using the
fragment
we'll grab this and just in case and see
actually we should grab the fragment cuz
that's what we really need so let's go
into the fragment I don't know why we be
getting an error from that but this is
something easy that we can test okay now
we don't want categories front post area
save that let's see what it says now
alright it worked for some reason it
just didn't like me using the post data
in there I don't know what I did
maybe I spelled it wrong I don't know
and I didn't notice it alright so let's
try it out here
oh-ho nice we have any on categorise
yeah we do
it works ah it works
oh man I'm exhausted okay so we did
finally get it to work
thanks in big part to to Jason I know
he's not he's not in here anymore
watching but definitely it was a huge
huge help so glad he decided to watch
glad I decided to tag tag the plug-in in
the Twitter post I did before the stream
so okay let's let me check through the
live chat to see if there any questions
I've been keeping up with the live chat
more than normal since I was having so
much trouble so I don't think there's
too much in the live chat but if you do
have a question you want to throw it in
there now that's cool I will still try
to get through all the questions I know
it's been a long stream but I actually
got into work late today so I don't have
a problem with staying later than normal
okay I do want to check my phone and
make sure my wife didn't call me let's
see No all right she called me earlier
he couldn't find her keys so she can't
get into the house without the keys so
she might stop in to get them from me
we'll see alright okay actually you know
what I'm gonna do first I'm gonna commit
these changes
first because I've been forgetting to
commit the changes and I don't I don't
want to have anybody try to submit a
pull request without these changes and
then it's just gonna cause a lot of
merge conflicts so let me find there we
go
that is all right I changed a lot of
stuff commit and let's just say on
display
all right that's not exactly everything
we did because we had single category
pages before we just changed how we're
getting the data so that we could grab
less data but that's fine with me my
brain is fried at this point I don't
want to think of a better commit message
so it's interesting we still didn't have
linting going on on commit so I've
totally forgot to check out why that's
happening so for now we don't have it I
guess I could do
lint whoa we have confined plug-in use
it in four
pretty sure I installed all the packages
yeah it did weird okay you're
I'll show that again alright great it
worked this time okay
okay now everything is and get um great
so now we can check out the questions
whoo all right I'm gonna scroll way up
okay I think I figured out where I left
off
maybe I didn't let me keep scrolling
okay so right around the time when I
realized my mistake of having the doing
all our tests for graph QL and having it
pointing to the wrong WordPress
installation
so Abba now says hey Jessie we're okay
with the challenges we're happy at least
you found the error along the line so
thanks X is saying that Marco says let
me go back in the stream and see it
again Patrick says if I had a dollar for
every time something silly like this has
happened to me I would be a millionaire
thanks Pat sir
Evan L says Jason you are tough your
contribution and participation has so
much lifted me yeah definitely Jason was
oh man so much help really awesome I'm
so glad we decided to use the WP graph
QL plugin because jason has been super
helpful and yeah yeah just amazing so
yeah I definitely I read I wish I had
more time I'd love to contribute to that
plug-in so if any of you are interested
in some PHP stuff check out that plug-in
and see if you can contribute and help
Jason out cuz I mean he's he's been a
great help to us here in a stream so
hopefully at some point I'll be able to
contribute to to the plug-in as well
okay
all right so I think I think this is
pronounced yarn its Jo RN but the O has
a little slash through it so correct me
if I'm wrong but I think it's yarn says
I sympathized recently I had two
one-hour hunts in one day we're googling
the air is brought up just a few
esoteric instances that had nothing to
do with my problem man I feel for you
there I I know how that is that's just I
can't believe that happened twice in one
day
two one-hour hunts yeah that's that's
tough but it's definitely it's really
encouraging to hear do you all have same
problems like that okay okay Jason did
say I said hey this was super fun but I
have to step away happy to chat with
anyone at any time it's Twitter at WP
graph QL also WP graph QL calm and then
the slack you can go join the slack
channel WP gql - slack Heroku app com
awesome okay
all right a boo now says thanks so much
congratulations to all say hi to your
beautiful baby and wife oh thanks Evan
oh yeah I I will do that yeah I couldn't
I was late this morning to work partly
because I just couldn't I couldn't leave
my my kids I had the two littlest ones
were still at home they don't go to
school yet and so they were home when I
was just having a good time hanging out
with them and finally I had to leave but
they're just so cute okay all right John
Hanson said I have found getting Adam
eslint and yes linfer react JSX set up
to work together as
to edit that can be a bit tricky once
set up it's great helps point out errors
I know you know what I've had several of
you have suggested that I do it like
that and I totally agree I really do
want to set it up like that I just I
just have not taken the time to actually
do it I either forget about it when I do
have the time or I just have too much
going on to be honest with you this week
has just been crazy with like a lot of
little things that I have to do a lot of
different projects and I've just been so
scattered
it's just been difficult for me you know
trying to get to anything
I'm just trying things are coming in and
I'm trying to get them done because I
have to and I can't really set aside the
time that I need for some of these other
things so hopefully it'll slow down a
bit we got some projects that should
finish up here soon and then then I can
focus more Mandella effects is what's
the link to the plugin yeah let me copy
that in for you into the live chat I had
that here let's copy that I'm copying it
in right now if you're not in the live
chat it's you know look at WP - graph QL
on github
okay so it's it's like the the name I
was trying to pronounce before is it's
like urine so okay cool I have to work
on my pronunciation urine if you don't
mind me asking where are you from
I'd like to wait to be able to pronounce
I guess and it would help if I know the
general area and then I could maybe have
a better shot at pronouncing names like
that my my coworker just waved to me I
don't think you could see it from this
camera but he just waved to me in the
door he's the one that I said a few days
ago they used to hang out with the
wu-tang clan in the late 90s he came
back again let's see okay okay Norwegian
so it's so it is it's urine and correct
me if that's wrong but I think it's
urine from and it's Norwegian okay
awesome
I'll do my best to try to remember that
if I mess it up again please let me know
don't let me slide on mispronouncing
names because I I want to I think it's
like being courteous to pronounce
someone's name correctly and to take the
time to try to learn it it shows respect
so I do want to do that so I won't be
offended if you remind me again about
how to pronounce your name I do want to
get them right okay I think that's it I
might I'm at the bottom of the live chat
here this has been it's been difficult
working through all this but this has
been a lot of fun it's a really fun
stream so it feels great whenever you
finally get when you finally get
something working alright your incest
close enough I'm going to look up my
Norwegian pronunciation and
and try to get it get it right maybe oh
there's there's got to be a youtube
video or something of somebody
pronouncing your name correctly I'll get
it
yeah but thanks for sticking around
there's not that many people that
actually stuck around to the end and I
totally understand this has been long
and crazy but thank you all for for
being here and helping out in the live
chat I will be back tomorrow
what's tomorrow Thursday yeah Wow this
week's going fast I'll be back tomorrow
probably sometime around 2:00 if I can
get to stream in a little earlier like
1:30 maybe I'll try that because I know
there was someone who is getting too
late for him so maybe I'll try to do it
earlier if I can
but until then have a great day I'll see
you tomorrow